on a la droite la plus bête du monde et
non pas parce qu'elles seraient en
manque d'idée cette fois ci parce que au
contraire on voit que les français
adhèrent à ces idées ces 45 % quasiment
de lax des électeurs qui votent à droite
en prenant toutes les droites et cette
droite là c'est droite là n'arrivent pas
à se trouver un chef à l'express
organisé et encore une fois le montre en
quoi elles sont
totalement prises dans des jeux
d'appareils ou des jeux de pouvoir ou
des annulations de personnages me soit
qu'on a effectivement la droite la plus
gâtée du monde 1 qui a suffisamment
d'élus suffisamment de temps pour passer
son temps à se quereller savoir qui va
être le chef à la place du chef il y
avait cette image un des requins dans un
aquarium n'y a pas assez de place pour
tout le monde là il ya même plus de
requins il ya simplement un aquarium
mais il ya toute une place parce qu'il
ya vraiment beaucoup trop de monde avec
cette idée de dire est ce qu'on peut
continuer avec cette idée de droite
réconciliables en fait je crois que
c'est pas la droite la plus bête du
monde c'est peut-être la droite qui
commence à se poser des questions sur
son avenir et dire il n'y a pas une
droite mais des droites en france et
elles ont là toute latitude pour
s'exprimer et c'est peut-être le risque
justement de voir éclater un monopole ou
du mois une position dominante en
politique